Berlin, die Stadt, die wächst.
An jeder Ecke wird gebaut.
40.000 Neu-Berliner jedes Jahr.
Wer kaufen will,
muss tief in die Tasche greifen.
Die Quadratmeterpreise haben sich
in den letzten 10 Jahren verdoppelt.
Ein Preistreiber: immer mehr
Luxusappartements im Stadtzentrum.
Diese Terrasse gehört zu einer
90-Quadratmeter-Wohnung –
verkauft für 700.000 Euro.
Die künftigen Bewohner freuen
sich auf den Umzug,
sind aber auch nachdenklich.
Ich hab ein bisschen Sorge, dass
die Stadt weniger interessant wird,
dass so ’n bisschen die Kunstszene
und die Kreativszene ein
bisschen zurückgedrängt werden,
weil die Mieten steigen, so dass
die Leute, die wenig Einkommen haben,
das nicht mehr bezahlen können.
Das macht mir ein bisschen Sorge,
dass Berlin sich so hinentwickelt
zu einer sehr teuren Stadt, die
dann nicht mehr so interessant ist.
Im Zentrum des Streits: die Altbauten.
Wie schnell und wie hoch dürfen die Mieten
steigen nach einer teuren Sanierung?
In diesem Haus sind fast alle Mieter raus
– bis auf eine Wohngemeinschaft.
Sie hat geklagt:
Die Sanierung sei teurer als nötig
und hätte ihre Miete verdreifacht.
Die Folge: Räumungsklagen und
Nervenkrieg mit dem Eigentümer.
Noch immer laufen Gerichtsverfahren.
Dies ist eine Mieterstadt, es gibt einen
Schutz dafür, es gibt darauf ein Recht.
Und da kommt niemand
daher und kauft einfach
und schmeißt mich mit
solchen Methoden raus.
Es brodelt in der Stadt.
Die Auseinandersetzung zwischen
Eigentümern und Mietern verschärft sich.
Es gibt Zwangsräumungen,
Polizeieinsätze, Demos.
Und die Berliner diskutieren:
Wem gehört eigentlich ihre Stadt?
Ein kleiner Teil gehört ihm:
Jacob Mähren.
Der Berliner startete vor 15 Jahren im
Immobiliengeschäft – mit einer Wohnung.
Heute sind es mehr als 2000,
und deren Wert steigt weiter.
Die Mieter, betont er, sind für
ihn keine Gegner, sondern Partner.
Unser Geschäftsmodell basiert
nicht darauf, dass
wir den Mieter rauswerfen
und die Wohnung dann verkaufen,
sondern im Gegenteil: Ohne den Mieter
könnten wir dieses Geschäft nicht betreiben.
In der Regel tun wir was für den
Mieter, wir entwickeln das Haus,
wir machen eigentlich das
gesamte Objekt wohnlicher.
Ja, und wenn das Objekt Leerstand hat
oder auch Leerstand bekommt, weil
einfach Leute kündigen oder ausziehen,
sanieren wir in der Regel die Wohnungen,
wenn sie im unsanierten Zustand sind,
und vermieten diese dann neu.
Und dann wird’s auch ein bisschen teurer?
In der Regel, wenn wir Geld
investieren, wird’s teurer, ja klar.
Die Mieten in Berlin sind rasant gestiegen:
um über 50 Prozent in
den letzten fünf Jahren
auf durchschnittlich zehn Euro pro
Quadratmeter.Geht das so weiter?
Dass sich die Mieter fürchten
vor einer Entwicklung, wie
sie in den letzten Jahren war –
ich glaube, da kann ich ihnen
ein bisschen die Angst nehmen,
also, das ist meine persönliche Vermutung.
Ich glaube, dass nach wie vor
sich der Berliner Markt entwickelt,
sowohl was Kaufpreise angeht,
auch Mieten,
aber eben nicht in der Geschwindigkeit
wie in den letzten Jahren.
Trotzdem: Bei den Berliner Mietern
ist das Misstrauen groß.
Dieses Haus sollte verkauft werden.
An wen, sagte man den Mietern nicht.
Sie hatten Angst um ihr Zuhause und fanden
eine ungewöhnliche Lösung: selbst kaufen.
Die Idee ist quasi, dass nicht … also,
dass uns das Haus als Kollektiv gehört
und wir alle aber weiterhin Miete zahlen,
aber geringe Mieten und
garantiert geringe Mieten.
Damit wir eben bleiben können,
das ist sozusagen unser Ziel.
Die Idee kommt vom sogenannten
„Mietshäuser Syndikat“.
Das hilft auch dabei, mehr als zwei
Millionen Euro aufzutreiben.
Wir als „Mietshäuser Syndikat“ haben
gute Kontakte zu Banken und Stiftungen,
die das Grundkapital, das
Fremdkapital finanzieren können.
Also, ein Haus braucht
80 Prozent Fremdkapital,
das heißt also, die größte
Summe kommt von der Bank.
Trotzdem: kein Hauskauf ohne Eigenkapital.
Damit aus den Mietern Eigentümer
werden, müssen sie viel Geld beschaffen.
Hier müssen etwa 400.000
Euro darüber aufgebracht werden.
Und diese 400.000 Euro kommen über
viele kleinere Kredite zusammen.
Das sind Kredite im Allgemeinen, die
zwischen 1000 und 5000 Euro liegen
von den Leuten selber, von Freunden
und Bekannten.
Gehört das Haus erst ihnen, stehen die
Bewohner vor ganz ungewohnten Fragen.
Damit das Projekt sich rechnet,
müssen sie sich selbst die Miete erhöhen.
Wie funktioniert das?
Ja, das funktioniert so, dass wir halt
auch das versuchen,
in der Gemeinschaft zu entscheiden halt.
Also, wir treffen uns zum
Beispiel unten im Hof, trinken was,
grillen und diskutieren halt,
was wir bezahlen können.
Wir haben wirklich am Anfang einfach
Umfragen gemacht und gesagt:
Ganz spontan, wie viel würdet
ihr erhöhen können?
Und daraufhin haben wir Antworten
bekommen, die wir schon mal als erste[n],
sozusagen, Ansatz haben nehmen können.
Und, ja, und das diskutieren wir einfach.
Ganz Berlin diskutiert:
Wie teuer darf Wohnen werden?
Und: Wem gehört die Stadt?